congratulations on this movie it's such
a fun time
um my first question is probably the
most important one which is what is your
favorite Beanie Baby
Oh my god oh I should have prepped
myself for this question I don't have
one I did I wasn't a Beanie Baby
person
um I I you know I I don't know I do like
I I don't I think his name is legs the
Frog
um I think that's the one that I have
probably handled the most in my uh
Beanie Baby uh life that's so fair
that's such a good choice
um you have such great chemistry with
everyone in this movie but I have to say
I think some of my favorite scenes are
the ones with the family with um Sarah
snook and also Delaney Quinn and Madison
Johnson what was it like to sort of
shoot those scenes
um and develop chemistry with all of
them I think develop I think
chemistry on camera is the hardest thing
especially with children right you're
like
I'm playing someone that doesn't really
know the kids but I'm trying to charm
the kids to charm the mother so that's
that's always tricky for me but uh you
know you're always I think Sarah is such
a top top actress that I think it was a
comfort level there that uh
and you know I always have a confidence
problem with my acting I I don't come
from the schools that a lot of actors I
get to work with or that don't I don't
have the training they do I just don't I
used to tell diarrhea jokes in coffee
houses and somehow I'm in movies it
doesn't make sense I'll be the first to
admit it so when I'm surrounded by like
really good quality actors like
Elizabeth and Sarah
uh it's helpful to me when they're kind
and nice
uh but but you that's a tricky thing is
to find that chemistry and for me also
to play Charming is is also difficult to
to
try to find a charm that doesn't seem
put on even though I do feel like his
charm was put on I think there was a
Showmanship to his charm so uh but but
the chemistry with the family Sarah
definitely helped helped me with that
stuff yeah definitely I think you
very eccentric the detail that I really
loved is his like love of chocolate milk
he's always drinking chocolate milk I'm
curious what was the thing that sort of
helped you understand or get into his
mindset uh I mean
it almost sounds too easy but in the
book there were passages about his
childhood and his past
and also Zach bassinet in the book also
kind of revealed that a lot of toy
makers have checkered bad childhoods
um so having known that about him
uh you know my little more Monday
morning uh Carl Young or or or Freud
kind of would try to play with what that
meant in my own brain sometimes that'll
bring uh
somebody can be narcissistic that comes
from that
sometimes they can be babies they can
you know they they
and they feel unprotected and I think
Tai was someone that felt unprotected at
his core
and I think he built this world around
him to feel uh yielded uh for the rest
of the world but that's just me that's
just my little psychological so I can
help try to figure out the character no
I think that that definitely makes a lot
of sense um I have to rap now but it was
so great speaking to you and I'm so
excited for everyone to see the movie
thanks so much thank you very much